>> THEY ALL HAVE MEDICAL DEGREE
AS WELL UNDERSTAND.
JOINING ME IS DR. MEHMET OZ.
THEY ARE ALL VERY EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN ON
TUESDAY.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT JOHN
FEDERMAN THAT HE REVIEWED USES
TO TALK ABOUT THE POLICIES.
WHAT CAN WE MAKE OF THIS?
>> THIS ENTIRE CAMPAIGN HE'S
AVOIDED TALKING ABOUT THE
KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES THAT OUR
PLAGUING PENNSYLVANIANS.
YOU MENTIONED AND IS THE POLICY.
I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS DATE.
THERE IS A LOT OF NATURAL GAS
RIGHT BENEATH MY FEET.
THAT IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE AUDIT WOULD ALSO REDUCE
INFLATION BECAUSE ENERGY PRICES
DRIVE ABOUT THREE IF THEY HAVE.
IT'S GREAT FOR NATIONAL SECURITY
.
IT MAKES US MORE FORMIDABLE FOR
OUR ENEMIES.
IF YOU GO TO A DINER THE PERSON
SERVED ME COFFEE KNOWS A TON
ABOUT ENERGY POLICY.
HE IS STUCK IN THE RIGID
IDEOLOGY, HE HAS THIS BELIEVE
THAT THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS THE
ONLY WAY FORWARD.
HE HAS BEEN DISMISSIVE OF THE
ENERGY INDUSTRY HERE FOR HIS
ENTIRE TENURE, CALLED IT A STAI
ON PENNSYLVANIA ARGUED THERE
SHOULD BE A MORATORIUM ON
DRILLING AND HAS HAD SOME PRETT
HARSH THINGS THAT REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO AR
WORKING IN THESE INDUSTRIES AND
HE HAS TRIED TO FLIP-FLOP ON
THAT.
PEOPLE HAVE CALLED IT OUT FOR
HIM.
THAT IS JUST AN EXAMPLE OF HIS
WEAK POSITIONS ON CRIME, DRUGS,
AND OPEN BORDER, IN HIS
POSITIONS ON THE ECONOMY AND
GENERAL.
WHILE I WAS TALKING ABOUT ISSUE
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
PENNSYLVANIA TAXPAYERS, HE'S
BEEN MAKING ATTACKS ON ME.
AFTER A WHILE IT JUST BECOMES
GOSSIP IT DOESN'T HAVE AN IMPAC
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MAKE PEOPLE'
LIVES BETTER.
I WANT TO GET RID OF THE
EXTREMIST IDEAS IN WASHINGTON.
>> TO THAT POINT, FETTERMAN
RECENTLY HAD THE NERVE TO BRAG
ABOUT HIS DISASTROUS CRIME
RECORD.
WATCH.
>> THE TRUTH IS I'M THE ONLY
CANDIDATE IN THIS RACE THAT HAD
HANDS-ON KIND OF EXPERIENCE
AGAINST FIGHTING AGAINST CRIME.
I WAS THE FOUR TERM MAYOR OF A
COMMUNITY FOR ALMOST 14 YEARS
AND I MADE IN VIOLENCE AT THE
CENTER OF ALL OF MY FOCUS.
>> GIVEN HIS BACKGROUND DR. OZ
HOW CAN HE CREDIBLY CLAIMED TO
HAVE A STRONG STANCE ON CRIME
GIVEN HIS VIEWS ON BAIL REFORM,
POLICING, AND EVERYTHING ELSE?
HOW DOES THIS ADD UP?
>> HE CAN'T.
VIOLENCE INCREASED IN THE SMALL
TOWN HE WAS MAYOR OF.
THE POLICE AT THAT COMMUNITY
HAVE SUPPORTED ME.
I HAVE BEEN ENDORSED BY THE
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT JOHN
FETTERMAN DOESN'T HAVE THEIR
BACK.
IT IS JUST AN IMAGE OF A MAN WH
DOESN'T OFFER WHAT HE'S
PROMISING.
IF YOU'RE UPSET ABOUT THIS, AND
YOU SHOULD BECOME A HE RAISED
OVER $2 MILLION SO PLEASE GO TO
DR. OZ.COM AND SUPPORT MY
EFFORTS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO BUY
THE SEAT BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAV
A CANDIDATE THAT CAN EXPRESS WH
HIS EXTREME VIEWS MAKE SENSE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT VIEWS THAT
ALIGN WITH THE VALUES OF
PENNSYLVANIANS.
WE CAN BALANCE A BUDGET, WE KNO
HOW TO DEAL WITH CRIME AND LET
PEOPLE DO THEIR JOBS, ESPECIALL
COPS, MAKE SURE THE BORDER IS
SECURE, THAT WAY YOU WILL SHUT
DOWN THE CARTEL THAT ARE
BRINGING THE FENTANYL ACROSS.
DR. OZ WE HAVE A QUESTION FROM
THE AUDIENCE, MICHAEL DUKE FROM
SCOTT STILL HAS A QUESTION.
>> GOOD EVENING DR. OZ, MY
QUESTION FOR YOU IS, WITH THE
PROSPECT OF REPUBLICANS
REGAINING MAJORITIES IN BOTH
CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS WHICH YOU
PREPARED TO DO TO ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE SUCH AS THE RECORD HIGH CPI
, RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES, AND
JUST AN OVERALL HIGH COST OF
LIVING?
>> THE NUMBER ONE AND EASIEST
MOVE IS TO FREE US TO BE ABLE T
DRILL ON FEDERAL LANDS.
THOSE FEDERAL LANDS ARE ALL OF
OURS AND THERE IS NO REASON THA
WITHIN A WEEK HE WAS ABLE TO
BAND DRILLING AND THOSE AREAS.
WE ALSO HAVE TO SEND MESSAGE TO
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY THAT WE
BELIEVE THEY ARE IMPORTANT TO
THE SUCCESS OF OUR NATION.
THESE FOLKS ARE LIVING IN FEAR.
JOHN FETTERMAN SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO PROSECUTE THEM BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T LIKE WHAT THEY WERE
DOING GREAT ENERGY IS A
COMMODITY, FREE PEOPLE, UNLEASH
PEOPLE, TO BE ABLE TO DO JUST
THAT.
HERE IN PENNSYLVANIA WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
.
THERE IS NO REASON WHY ANY
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP SHOULD DO
THIS, THEY DO IT BECAUSE IT'S A
WAY OF SINGLING TO PEOPLE IN TH
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT THEY CARE
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT IS TO GET THE
NATURAL GAS OUT IT PRESERVES AR
IN FIREMEN 50 OIL IS A LOT
DIRTIER THAN NATURAL GAS.
THEY'RE WORKING AGAINST THE.
DR.